[A] What are some of the things that you do in your life
[A] or words that you've heard
[A] or lessons that you've internalized
[A] to help you move through the difficult moments in life?
[B] You have to get used to being criticized.
[B] I've often been ridiculed for believing in blockchain technology.
[B] I've been treated like that from friends and families
[B] because I'm a visionary.
[B] I personally think AI is gonna be
[B] in the similar place blockchain's at
[B] in about three or four years.
[B] They got infinite money now.
[B] We had infinite money five years ago.
[B] It's the same stuff.
[B] But the real builders are gonna stick around
[B] and they're gonna make innovation and things happen.
[B] So that's what I'm here for.
[B] Cool.
[A] I could drop the mic right now if it didn't belong to me.
[A] Dude.
[A] That's fucking...